today i'm pleased
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
[Music]
convalescence
from the blood of recovered patients to
help treat patients battling a current
infection convalescence
because of operation
convolution today i'm pleased to make a
truly historic announcement in our
battle against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
we provided 48 million dollars to fund
the mayo clinic study that tested the
efficacy of convalescence
the virus
[Music]
convalescence
convalescent
all right we're taking it from the top i
thought i was live there i was talking
to you guys and for some reason i
my camera was not there so we are
standing by now for the uh
inevitable release of donald trump back
to the white house
marine one is arriving now at walter
reed medical center
this maybe is ill-advised maybe not we
don't know the true health status of
donald trump in terms of his coronavirus
his lawyer his doctors rather they sound
more like lawyers
his doctors have been uh very very much
dishonest about what's going on donald
trump receiving treatments
often which would be only for more
serious cases of coronavirus and the
explanation is well he's the president
then that may be true or it may not be
true
donald trump has also been um
sort of manic in terms of his twitter
behavior
and uh donald trump often gets that way
at the same time
one of the side effects of dexamethasone
and many other
corticosteroids is it can be a
corticosteroid-induced mania that is a
thing that is a
symptom so we just don't know the other
thought that some doctors are suggesting
is
trump may be feeling good and ready to
go because that's what steroids do to
you
until you start coming down and then
maybe trump isn't doing so well i'm not
pretending to know what i'm telling you
is
it seems trump is alive and it seems
trump has coronavirus other than that i
don't think we really know that much and
this is going to be a very very
uh eventful week as many are saying in
the chat we're keeping an eye on
various streams here for you wednesday
night kamala harris scheduled to debate
mike pence mike pence
leaving to utah earlier this afternoon
saying trump says he's doing well
so i'm headed out to utah the harris
campaign
has i actually tweeted earlier today
um i would love to see kamala wearing a
mask
and bringing her own plexiglas during
wednesday's debate i was sort of joking
whoops i took myself off there sorry
about that uh kamala asked for plexi
class
i don't know how long i've been gone
kamala asked for plexiglas
and uh the trump people said no
plexiglas
i want her to bring plexiglas much like
jamie harrison did over the weekend to
his debate with
senator lindsey graham so we will see
what happens there
we also heard just about an hour ago
that donald trump plans to be at the
debate next thursday donald trump
who has been deceptive about when he
tested positive first
for coronavirus we know on the hannity
program last thursday at 9 00 pm 10 pm
eastern he said he was waiting for test
results
he had actually already had a positive
test result at that point in time
we don't know if he was experiencing
symptoms on wednesday
doctors suggest that he was likely
contagious by tuesday when he was on
stage with joe biden we don't really
know how long trump's had it
we don't know how long trump's been
contagious we don't know how long trump
will be contagious but
he we are now being told trump plans to
be at the debate
next thursday and without a doubt they
will be framing this
as big powerful trump beat
the virus he did it he did it and they
will use this to foment the idea
that this is no big deal and so on and
so forth so
as of where we are right now all we know
is we are
at walter reed medical center here
donald trump scheduled to leave walter
reed at the bottom of the hour
scheduled to arrive back at the white
house
um 10 minutes after that so that is what
is going on i do want to mention just
one
other thing let me see how i do this i'm
just gonna plug
i have an element here excuse me while i
just plug in a new element i have
i have obtained at the recommendation of
some in my audience
i've obtained a oh there we go tablet
and stylus because i've been asked
sometimes when i do for example finance
or economics topics
it's been recommended you know it would
be great if you could like whiteboard
some of these concepts
i have no clue how this thing works when
i was just using it
yeah now it's working as a mouse but at
some point i think i'm going to get this
working let me see if i can do
what happens if i press whiteboard
uh dear god i don't know what is going
on
hopefully this doesn't pull my stream
offline but in any case
um this is something i hope to have
going it's a wacom tablet
if anybody knows how what i would like
to do
is almost to use it like a telestrator
where i could just even draw over the
video we're looking at right now
let me see if i can do this whiteboard
microsoft whiteboard oh my god i don't
know what this is
this is i didn't realize it was going to
start installing things
but i just want to be
definitely do not send diagnostic data
okay so let's just i'm just gonna test
this okay
here's white
oh look yeah i can draw stuff oh but you
know what's really annoying whenever i
lift and tap
it goes to a different monitor okay
so hopefully at some point if somebody
knows how to
get it to default only to this because
the problem is
as soon as i lift and tap it moves me to
a different
monitor and that's not what i want i
want to be able to draw on this monitor
so that's that let me unplug it
there we go and if anybody if anybody
knows how to use that what what i want
is uh for it to default to this
particular monitor i think we will be
all much much better off with that uh in
place
okay let me see what's on people's minds
via super chat we have a hype train
going on twitch
we we have a lot of different things
going here
first and foremost big thank you as we
wait for donald trump here sonia bright
is new member number one today at
joinpakman.com
and james dewine is new member number
two
i appreciate both of you kicking us off
as you see
uh that that has a real impact on uh the
graphics
that we display let's see what's on
people's minds chaka seki says anyone
want a hazard a bet that trumpeto
crumps in one week as his body produces
hamburger antibodies
that cause him to swell up into a giant
trumpkin
wow okay austin klein says
big fan david but please pull back on
the click bait titles i get it started
as a joke
i'm guessing it really does generate
clicks for you it cheapens your show
and turns it into the very thing you set
out to satirize
i completely with full respect and peace
and love
i disagree i completely disagree
jake says we need to yeet this
plasma president oh my god
daniel says would trump take
responsibility if one of the nine dies
one of the nine what do you mean supreme
court justices or
is it nine people from his
administration that have
tested positive i don't know what the
nine means
gary says he put his driver at risk
yesterday just to say hi to his
supporters
yeah he also hilariously tweeted
um where was this oh my god he's going
crazy now
wait a second where was that tweet here
it is he said it is reported that the
media is upset because i got into a
secure vehicle to say thank you to the
many fans and supporters who were
standing outside of the hospital for
many hours and even days to pay their
respect to their president
if i didn't do it media would say rude
on what planet would media come out if
trump
if contagious trump just stayed in his
hotel room
what media outlet would have said
trump's being rude by not driving around
while he's contagious with coronavirus
nobody would have done it nobody would
have done it that's absolutely
ridiculous
um let's see here
kaylee mcinerney i'm trying to get
caught up on some of the things
kaylee mcinanni did test positive um
what else william barr we don't know
what's going on with william barr
because he was exposed at minimum by
kellyanne conway
and he initially was not going to
quarantine
now he is going to quarantine and we
don't know
too much else about whether he's
contagious
uh or or what is going on keeping an eye
on some different feeds here various
feeds
what else do we have mike michael hawk
says almost got me michael hawk says as
a young immigrant to the u.s did your
parents teach you the metric system
similar to spanish
i always had metric as a concurrent so
for example
you know i was going to school and it
would be like wow it's going to be 90
tomorrow and then my dad would would say
oh well that's like
what i'm guessing here what's 90 is 90
uh
is that 38 or something like that let me
look that up
90 f to c
32 oh my god i'm way off well clearly it
didn't take
clearly it didn't take but yes i always
had a metric
in my uh in my periphery so to speak
e tac nar says thank you for doing live
coverage it's been
invaluable the past few weeks i
appreciate that thank you very much
by the way these are super chats up on
the screen okay
if you'd like to get a message up on the
screen that's for the 12
000 of you watching on youtube it's the
dollar symbol
you can also participate via twitch i do
want to say a few things about what's
happening on twitch right now
um larry kenobi has subscribed with
prime
fox kicking with kara nelson b
satter94 sherry
siender shepard detonation has
subscribed
eric ponner face plant
kagers says thank you david i appreciate
you your team and your work
thank you i i appreciate you being here
we you have not missed anything donald
trump trump scheduled ooh
a trump flag now waving in front of the
camera the sycophants are there
um we are waiting for trump scheduled to
leave walter reed eight minutes from now
expected at the white house 18 minutes
from now and of course the speculation
is that the last few days coronavirus
particularly
in folks who have who are overweight who
have other comorbidities
it can have waves and so donald trump
right now is all
you know roided up on corticosteroids
and realistically could be feeling okay
maybe it was never that serious
we don't know his doctors are lying
constantly
the idea is the speculation is that the
facilities at the white house from a
standpoint of medical
medical elements have been updated at
the white house
to to essentially allow for an icu
at the white house if necessary the
optics of trump leaving
powerful trump leaving uh are what they
are going for here
thanks to the raid from the serfs over
on twitch welcoming 327 people
as we are of course waiting for donald
trump
to leave uh walter reed medical center
he is to be discharged seven minutes
from now
and we will see if indeed that happens
and what trump's physical appearance i
would expect that the orange makeup will
be back today i assume that they want
the best
according to according to what you know
they think
looks good they want the best looking
possible trump
big thank you to matt boyvin matt boyvin
is new member number three today
at joinpakman.com other super chats are
coming in
david cooper says it's going to be
excruciating when he's boasting about
beating the chinese virus
at his stupid rallies yes it is
it's going to be cringe for sure
um other super chats coming in sorry i
skipped past a few
stupid rallies there it is skitoshi
nakayabro
says trump at the debate what the hell
this is literal insanity why does no one
stop this how did we get here yeah if
you're just joining us a trump advisor
recently said like an hour ago trump
plans to debate next thursday
in person with joseph r biden jr so it's
three day
covered for trump by the way people who
were laughing when i was calling it
coveted
that's how they say it in britain but
you know
i'm developing a mid-atlantic accent
received pronunciation
so i don't think there's anything wrong
with me pronouncing it covet i think
it's great
dinosaur tony says you'll need the
official official drivers and access to
wacom settings
there you can map the stylus to your
preferred display yeah i've got the
drivers installed
and so i so you're saying i can map
the stylus to just one display you know
while we're waiting
let's just try it i'm going to do that
real quick let's see if we can do it
we are re-plugged
ah there it is there's the beautiful
sound
and let me see if i can find pen
settings
pen settings uh so i'm a lefty that's
good
pen shortcuts hmm
i think it might be in some other
settings let me take a look here
yeah it would be a really really great
thing
to be able to get this thing going let's
see
wacom tablet properties there it is
ah beautiful okay mapping
and i want it only on okay so how do i
set it only to one monitor is the
question
right now it looks like all of my
monitors are selected
on screen controls
yeah it's not obvious i'll i'll have to
deal with it later
it does seem as though force
proportion screening ah monitor
okay here we go monitor three
beautiful okay we've now mapped it only
to monitor three
whiteboard
and then now over let's just see we're
doing a test
there it is it is now only monitor three
wow
this is fantastic yeah so the idea is
you know if i was doing some kind of
economic concept like
uh marginal utility of money we might
say
that you know if this is like one dollar
two dollars three dollars or something
like that
uh you'd actually that would be utility
and we would have dollars over here
the marginal utility of money for
example would go down over time probably
like this or oh my god it's i've got to
move it though you guys can't see a damn
thing
wow okay well listen it's not going
perfectly right now
clear canvas there we go i think this is
going to be really useful
now the other thing i would love to be
able to oh god i just clicked i'm sorry
the other thing that would be great
would be to be if anybody knows how i
could draw on this
because i think on this screen it's
working like a mouse right now i would
like to be able to
draw on this screen almost like a
telestrator
so you know during the debates i could
like draw a circle if something
interesting happened or
something like that that i don't know
what the settings are i don't know if
that is a
it doesn't sound like whiteboard
that part's more complicated but doable
okay very good listen i
i'm here to improve the streams for
everybody else
and uh so oh i i would need almost like
a transparent white board would be the
idea
email me okay somebody email me
there we go we're gonna unplug it just
so we don't have any other issues
perfect all right i'm so glad
everybody's with me here we are standing
by for donald trump
leaving walter reed medical center
momentarily there are camera people
out front although it's not clear
trump's going to be walking out the
front door
the helicopter seems to be in the back i
don't know
okay we're all here together political
puppy has just subscribed for 10 months
via twitch
with the question how widely do you
think trump supporters will believe his
words
don't be afraid of covid don't let it
dominate your life and will make the
corona situation worse
many i mean at this point you know 28 29
days out from the
election i don't know that it's even
that relevant to guess what
share of trump's followers are going to
believe him when he says this that or
the other thing
it's essentially uh it's academic at
this point
um but it will certainly be some who
will who will
follow what trump says and say hey
listen trump got it and he recovered
it's funny because a bunch of the trump
supporters don't believe he even has it
and then others are going to believe
it's no big deal because trump recovered
in three days
supposedly or whatever it is absolutely
crazy
it's crazy what's going on okay dan
l values says trump is the hamburglar
jacob ratner says what's your thoughts
on people wishing trump death i'm
against that listen
here's here's my perspective on this
donald trump's handling of coronavirus
has been sociopathic it has been
completely indifferent
to the death and suffering of the 214
thousand people who have now died
the millions who have gotten the um
uh virus the family members of those
right trump's been completely
indifferent so for me
it is reasonable to be indifferent to
trump getting coronavirus to wish him
death is further than i'm comfortable
going and i think we should we should
probably stop
short of that but indifference makes
absolute and perfect sense given trump's
indifference as well
remy lebro has subscribed for four
months and says
i really just want my notification to go
away
but if you're reading this pack i love
the show and appreciate the hard work
keep it up thanks remy
appreciate that thank you very much
okay man raj baines
says is there any chance of trump being
coveted free by the next debate
trump's people around trump are already
saying trump is going to debate
you tell me you tell me daniel says yes
one of the nine infected senators and
white house peeps okay very good
worm wood says david learn origami the
benefits are twofold nicely done
nicely done babe ruthless says vanity
fair is reporting don jr
wants an intervent intervention for
trump thinks he's manic on not and
not making sound decisions oh let's look
that up
very fair don jr trump manic could that
possibly be true
oh wow don jr thinks trump is acting
crazy the president's
covered joyride has the family divided
the president's recklessness at walter
reed has don jr pushing for an
intervention but ivanka and jared keep
telling trump how great he's doing
wow that is something uh
i am going to have to cover that
tomorrow for sure
uh thanks for letting me know just
emailing it to myself
that's crazy hey listen maybe don ju
we always said eric's the dumb one and
don jr
is not the dumb one so maybe don jr
actually is
is the person in the room who is making
some sense because that seems absolutely
accurate
but what's clear is we we increasingly
seem to have a house divided
um and by the way don jr half the half
the day seems like he's on something
david abel says the ratings from my
virus have been
huge believe me nathan
shocker says i'm a 3d artist you can
change the default monitor in wacom or
recalibrate okay we got that
now the question is how can i telestrate
blasian marine says the dod
reimbursement rate for the vh3d
marine one is around 24 000 per flight
hour
a mask costs less than this super chat
thank you very very powerful message
jeremy says i'm excited to see that more
and more of my politically engaged
friends have been watching and you're
enjoying your show lately great work
thank you yeah we actually you know i
got some very very ugly messages from
some viewers over the weekend saying
david you pathetic fool
you made it to a million and now you're
going to fail
like okay well a million subscribers is
already pretty good like if that's where
i get
that's still pretty good but we're
actually already at 1.03 million
and approaching 1.04 million so we're
we're doing beautifully
and uh be notified of future streams
including wednesday night live debate
stream with kamala harris
and mike pence just subscribe
free on youtube free free free on
youtube
you know something crazy happened on the
debate night the other night
when we started this this is you you
guys might find this interesting
when we started the debate stream a few
days ago we had 1.022 million
subscribers
and we had like 55 000 live viewers on
youtube 65 000 total
and the stream ended and we had the
exact same number of subscribers i said
this cannot be
this this can they didn't do me this way
and i spoke to my youtube rep and he
said you got
so many subscribers during your stream
that it
triggered for lack of a better term
actually for
i mean it's a perfect term it triggered
a sort of
spam verification thing where youtube
was like whoa whoa whoa stop the clock
you're getting so many subscribers we
need to
analyze that these are real not bots
and so then over the four days that
followed seven thousand subscribers
arrived because uh
it was just an incredible evening we hit
50 000
on twitch it was wild okay but enough
about that i want to hear from you guys
let's see what else we've got
jamie says this may be the very first
time trump is on time for something
by the way i love the clickbait titles
yeah so so
listen listen what i'm gonna say about
the clickbait titles um
the clickbait titles now are sort of
like part of the show
you should see how many other channels
now are copying my
bait titles like using shock in all caps
i created that within the small
left tube space okay i mean it's like i
didn't create capitalization i'm not
trump here i don't you know
i'm not taking credit but we developed
that
as a trope and now you see all these
different channels
left tube channels that i'm not even
going to mention using the exact
same thing okay uh
what's that word um plagiarism is the
sincerest form of flattery or something
like that
but i did make one mistake early last
week we taped a video
about trump metaphorically collapsing
during a press briefing
and the title said trump collapses
and then trump got coveted and that
video published on saturday
and a lot of people complained they said
david you know the guy's in the hospital
now you're saying he collapsed
and you guys were completely right it
was an oversight the the title was
chosen on tuesday
and it published on saturday and it said
collapsed and i understand why that you
know we were talking a metaphorical
collapse
so oh immediately i went in and changed
it to implodes i assumed nobody would
would actually think trump imploded in a
literal sense
so i was um i was more comfortable with
that
abs you guys were right i mean listen i
it was my bad
my bad so always i'm i'm willing to be
corrected on issues like that
donna williams says i work in an icu and
the noise trump supporters are making is
horrible for the patients in the
hospital
everything they are constantly doing is
terrible i'm not at all surprised
michigan mama says what happens if trump
deteriorates too critical at the white
house whose head goes on the chopping
block for putting potus at risk
that's why i believe as others do
that they've essentially built an icu at
the white house
so that they could hide that reality
it seems obvious and natural that that's
what they would do
kevin says hey david big fan and new
member do you think trump is going to
continue improving or is him leaving the
hospital more related to optics
you know it already makes oh let's
listen to see if there's an update hold
on he took
outside the hospital yesterday and as
more staffers from the west wing
including his press secretary kelly
mcinerney test positive for coronavirus
the cameras trained in the front door
when he arrived at the hospital
back on friday you may recall he stepped
off was ushered into a limo and then
taking in
an entrance out of view of the cameras
but now we're told he'll come out of the
front doors these the steps
that entrance may be familiar to viewers
who have seen uh the medical briefings
okay so anyway trump eight minutes late
already and uh there is some activity so
maybe he's going to come out
up so here's my thought i think that
trump's
improvements mean nothing because he
supposedly had a very mild case to begin
with although they conceded he needed
oxygen multiple times and is on multiple
treatments only for severe covid
then the every day they say he's been
improving improving from what how can
you improve
not noticeably when it wasn't serious to
begin with
it makes no sense we can't trust any of
it we just don't know
okay we are awaiting donald trump
momentarily
please consider yourself invited to grab
a membership
at joinpacman.com it is our number one
funding source a few folks who just
signed up are chris hubbell
who's new member number four today
jean-luc carran
is new member number five today
as we see donald trump here let's take a
look there is
there's donald trump
no n95 mr president how many staff are
fit
how many of your staff are spent thank
you very much
do you think you might be a super
spreader mr president
ah do you think you might be a super
spreader
no n95 president taking no
questions uh but certainly a
demonstration
a sign of strength how is no one wearing
an n95 here this guy is coronavirus
this guy has coronavirus nobody's
wearing an n95
absolutely ridiculous absolutely
ridiculous
wow what a projection of strength he
pumped his fist
annabella fernandez i appreciate your
support you are new member number six
today
at joinedpakman.com also sheldon novak
is number seven cameron carr is number
eight
and bennett schwartz is number nine uh
we are standing by now donald trump
being shepherded over
uh in a vehicle to the marine one
helicopter at which point it's only
about an eight to ten minute flight
back to the white house and that will be
coming very very soon
um there you can see the helicopter and
here we can see
the motorcade which will start bringing
trump what what a mess what an absolute
in total means
that whoever asked mr trump do you think
you could be a super spreader
just fantastic and remember guys trump
has coronavirus it's contagious he
shouldn't be around anybody
what will he do back at the white house
he's around people
it's a complete and total mess trump is
a bio weapon
he is an ignorant hopped up on
corticosteroids bio weapon right now
that's exactly what we have going on
uh yeah i'm gonna be here with you guys
once trump takes off we'll we'll follow
his entire path back to the white house
and he may even say something back
though i wouldn't be shocked trump is so
desperate
to uh you know do all of his idiotic
stuff
he may well have a mic set up when he
gets back to the white house
uh we will see about that okay uh
other super chats coming in wait a
second let's see where that is
i lost some super
uh where is it
okay who gets the nomination if trump
dies it's not automatic if trump were to
die the republican party would have to
decide they would have to do a new
nomination
uh what else do we have here
see what's going on as he has over the
course of the last several days
that he is in form able to work and
continues
with his routine but what's noticeable
is how little we really know about his
condition at this time
his doctor refusing to provide any
details about those lung scans
which is significant because it would
potentially be revelatory
about whether he has any covid related
effects possibly
pneumonia even as he heads back to the
white house the president
is taking a series of an antibody uh
experimental antibody cocktail he's
taking
every viral drug remdesavier also taking
dexamethasone that is a steroid lester
as we've been reporting that is
typically only used for
severely ill coronavirus yes you all
know that because i've been saying that
now for a couple of days
uh as you can see a contagious donald
trump with covid
wearing only a surgical mask a 10 cent
mask donald trump wearing there
very very bizarre
donald trump now being brought over to
marine one helicopter soon expecting him
back at the white house it's about an
eight or ten minute trip
between walter reed medical in bethesda
maryland
and the lawn of the white house
um and there is donald trump
walking on to marine one
and uh still wearing just that
surgical mask very odd
and soon we will see the caravan
of helicopters including presumably a
diversion helicopter
heading back to the white house chris
hawkins says i appreciate your
content and cutting through all the bs
it has it has me understand it all thank
you again
thank you deny armor
says thank you for encouraging me to
engage in politics and educating me with
objectivity and being honest in the
tragedy we are experiencing
29 days my friends 29 days
neurostream says excite excited for
real-time video markup with the stylus
yes
very much christian sola says what if
trump's doctor was your doctor
uh yeah i don't think so michael
zawadski says what's up plasma gang just
joined on the website today you are
essential daily listening found your
show during the primaries this year
appreciate that yeah by the way this if
you're just stumbling across my
feed today be it on youtube where we
have about 19 000 viewers
or twitch where we're closing in on a
couple thousand or the couple thousand
people watching on facebook
subscribe follow and like respectively
to be notified of future streams
wednesday evening starting a half hour
before the uh vice presidential debate
we will be live live live and you will
be notified of that
if you follow it's all free i'm selling
you nothing i'm selling you nothing
other than a good time with some nice
people
and sometimes you know people get banned
it does sometimes happen uh here is
marine one
uh spooling up very exciting
guys uh but of course what i was going
to point out one of the curious things
is the medical regimen the treatments
he's received some experimental some
considered very aggressive for
more serious cases of covid and that has
left a big
question mark over all this and
certainly is uh his
treating physician uh not wanting to go
into specifics about what the
lung scans look like or some of the
other key telltale
things that that doctors would look at
to evaluate right
cova 19 patients condition we know from
our reporting of this disease it can
show one way
at one time and then swing violently in
the other direction
with little warning and again doctors
say they have
what they need in the medical facilities
of the white house
uh dr john is with us dr dr john i'm
playing a doctor right there so
to pick up on what i was saying about
this idea that the question marks here
that make us wonder
if the the man who just climbed in that
chopper is as well as he appears let's
hear what the doctor says
and you know lester a couple days ago i
mentioned the word red flag and by red
flag i meant that
he was getting medications that they
usually reserve for patients who are
severely ill
so of the medications he's getting one
of them's room desevere that's the one
that peter was talking about
it's an antiviral so they give it to
patients early on
so that makes sense to give patients who
are mild or moderately sick
at that point because you're trying to
fight it off you're trying to actually
actively fight the virus with that
medication
the other one are the the antibodies
they were giving them the
the regeneron antibody cocktail the
monoclonal antibody cocktails they gave
them
because that also gives your immune
system a boost
so it's trying to actively fight off the
virus at that point but the third one
they gave them and this is the one that
raised some red flags
is the dexamethasone that's a steroid
and per nih protocol
that should only be given to patients
who are on ventilators or who are on
supplemental oxygen in the hospital
and they specifically say it is not
recommended for patients that are not on
a ventilator
not on supplemental oxygen but other
experts are saying you know at some
point
sometimes even if they're not at that
stage but they're severely ill
then we'll give them that dexamethasone
anyway but it's definitely reserved
for severely ill not mild so i think
what we're seeing here is the medication
they're giving them
is reserved for patients who are sicker
than they're telling us he
is and it's important with a steroid
because of the steroids given early on
when they're not that sick it actually
can make the patient worse and so
they're going to be very careful with
that so yeah in fact dexamethasone can
cause corticosteroid-induced mania which
you know if you look at trump's twitter
this morning is not a far it's not
far-fetched
it can also in some patients cause
delusions of grandeur which is complex
because you would not know
trump is constantly uh experiencing
delusions of grander so
if the dexamethasone was causing them in
trump which is a rare but serious side
effect
uh you wouldn't know you wouldn't know
because that's always trump
very very late to uh identify delusions
of grandeur in this gentleman
a few other folks i do want to thank for
signing up on my website
drew blake is new member number 10 today
also a shout out to kathy von bargan
who's new member number 11.
valerie miller is number 12.
mauricio reyes or as we say in argentina
right you guys all understand what i'm
talking about is number 13
kevin lomax is number 14 thomas leno
is number 15 and dennis hutch new member
number 16
at joinpackman.com very much appreciate
the support folks have been giving
through the website and by all means as
we wait here for a
welcoming party for donald trump at the
white house
remember this is a contagious sick man
and there are people all over the lawn
are they wearing n95s what are they
social distancing we don't yet know but
we will see
consider yourselves invited to grab a
membership at joinpakman.com there's a
coupon code right above my
head the coupon code i don't want to say
that you'll be prosecuted
but if people found out you were using
such an aggressive coupon code
it might generate interest from
authorities okay let me just put it that
way
uh donald trump's helicopter has now
joined a decoy
marine one helicopter as is often the
case
as we continue to track uh donald
trump's trip back
roy brown says that's not how we say
covet in britain oh gosh yeah i was
listening to maddie hassan who he's
british
and he said covet covet that's how he
was saying it
maybe he led me astray violet on fleur
says he better be asked why he was
airlifted to a hospital for what he
refers to as the sniffles it's actually
not that rare
for trump to be airlifted to walter reed
i don't think that's the area where we
want to focus
andrew tate says david you have a
beautiful head of hair love from
sacramento thank you i appreciate that
reacher will kick your ass says i
predict a heart attack in the near
future
sorry to say let's see if we have any
other messages coming in via twitch
sub not so many
not so many can someone give me a
phonetic
british pronunciation of kovid
just so i can get that right i would
like to see that
if anybody can do it
it doesn't make sense to me that the
british pronunciation would be covered
yeah see people are saying covered
that's what i'm seeing people say
covet yeah that's what i'm talking about
maybe i can't even maybe there's
something wrong with my hearing i don't
know
uh michigan wifey says sick of hearing
he'll be fine what about the trumpanzees
he'll be around
thin the herd uh it's a sort of uh
survival of the fittest so so to speak
in of a sort alistair forbes says
trump's health is perfect but it
improves all the time like a biological
shepherd tone yeah if you'd think trump
was at a hundred percent when he went to
walter reed
and he's been improving ever since covet
covet's been
the best thing for trump uh all right
we've got a couple different streams
washington post has gone black
they've they've blacked or browned out i
don't like how this is um
sort of jittery let's go over to this
feed this seems smoother
smoother feed donald trump's helicopter
now entering
what appears to be washington dc proper
yeah okay very good
i think we've successfully alienated the
british
contingent in the audience very good
corey davis says i feel great herman
cain that's very dark
that's very very dark acoustic theory
says march april may june july august
september
trust the doctors october this madness
yeah uh oh we've now lost the pbs feed
uh we now are back to it looks like a
parallel chopper now
is that that looks like probably dca
airport
um that the helicopters are now flying
in front of interesting view yeah that's
got to be dca yep
people agree with me very powerful
agreement
and depending on the angle
that runway actually lines up with the
washington monument but i think it's
reverse angle
and uh a lot happening here
it looks like the decoy chopper now
breaks off
and there is the washington monument
very very much so
and in comes donald trump and we will
see yeah i'm getting white bronco vibes
myself i don't
i like that reference in the chat um
i i completely agree with that
assessment
there is definitely a white bronco
element
okay sermon michael says i used to
respect the u.s when trump was elected
the u.s became a joke now i'm just
embarrassed for the us from australia
it's compulsory for us to vote and find
if you don't no electoral college
cameron carr says covid survivor here in
toronto
thanks for alleviating the weight of
fake news we receive up here
thank you brianna chamberlain says did
you notice one doctor said cardiac liver
and kidney were normal or improving
then the next day said liver and kidney
were normal cardiac issues
you're trying to make sense out of
something that makes no sense brianna i
com
none of it makes any sense trump was
fine all along and he's improved every
day
you know i mean it's like make make a
heads or tails out of it
a donald trump now landing on the lawn
of the white house
we will see we will see what we see
let me thank a few other people while i
have a moment
el cred has subscribed with prime salem
black
has subscribed with prime freedom jesus
has been around three months now on
twitch raynor cool
has subscribed a new website members
benjamin steinhausen
is new member number 17.
manuel miranda number 18
dan coburn number 19.
michael beckwith is new member number 20
today
steven liscetsky
is number 21. daniel carr is number 22.
as we see donald trump now just
seconds from touchdown back at the white
house after a heroic battle
with the coronavirus which was always
mild but saw drastic improvement every
day
thanks to treatments that would normally
only be for very serious patients
with which they gave trump out of an
abundance of caution
despite the fact that he never needed
any of it right you guys understand
president
at least part of his legs maybe as he as
he exits the chopper
so just a little more than 72 hours from
when the president departed
of the white house on a day that was
later acknowledged he had a drop in his
blood oxygen level
right and was showing other covid19
symptoms
president has now returned to the white
house to the residence where he will
continue to
convalesce his doctors held a news
briefing today and said they believe
that he is
medically able that he's indicated all
the
all the things they look for when they
decide whether to discharge
a patient we have noted uh there are
some questions about the aggressiveness
of the uh treatment regimen he's
received that have set off rede covid
amazing recovery it looks like they are
again blocking the live camera with the
chopper but typically after the fact
there is video that they run back
usually within just a few minutes home
and to convalesce and uh to isolate and
of course we don't
quite know what isolate will mean in the
case the president
noticing the door is being open right
now at the uh
white house residence we don't know if
we're gonna see
members of his family or uh hallie
jackson
uh i don't know if you're wearing people
will be waiting for him with hugs i'm
sure it just opened
uh do we know if there would be a
special greeting of the president there
you know we don't know for sure lester
but given what we've seen so far with
the optics of president trump wanting to
be seen
wanting to show the american public that
yes he can you know
walk out on his own he can appear on his
own i wouldn't be surprised i picked up
lester at the same time as you did on
the activity there
up on the balcony i will note typically
this is not a shot that our viewers
often see we don't normally have this
shot up and ready to go because we do
have reporters on the other side of
marine one
right where the president is departing
i'm watching the bottom of the screen
there to see if we can get any
indication as to when the president will
be stepping off the helicopter
lester i have to tell you at a moment
like this these are frankly some of the
most
scrutinized steps that president trump
has ever taken and possibly will ever
take the shot of him coming down the
stairs tapping that railing as you noted
you have to imagine bulbs are going off
so i assume he's coming down now and and
we may just not be
yep it looks like i see steps we may
just not be able to see him he's going
to be read into of course by people
across the country
and you have to think he knew that that
was going to be the case
here again the optics are important ever
since
lester i think back to 72 hours ago when
you and i were doing this almost to the
hour i was watching this
same helicopter off the south lawn here
and head to walter reed we're now
watching it set uh watching it come back
now
72 hours roughly it's gonna be him there
and even from the very beginning of this
lester it was important for the white
house to show the president
walking on his own power getting into
the helicopter on his own power yeah
there you go the president is obviously
not answering the questions
is that yeah i think hallie i think
we're watching the president now walking
up the stairs to the residence that's
not a way he normally goes in
again the walking up the stairs
certainly an image that he would be
eager
to display and then he will uh make his
way to that uh
those french doors draped in american
flags did he just take his mask off
we've seen him you're now gonna walk
around the entire white house with no
mask just spreading it to everybody
who's around him but this guy is
unbelievable this lady and wave to the
people who have assembled on the south
lawn that's
just to give some context to where this
is people might be thinking i can barely
see the president he looks so small on
the screen
we will have a better shot of this again
we are using a very long lens here from
far away to be able to bring this shot
to you live
there is going to be a better uh look at
the president here so we'll be able to
see sort of how he is how he's moving
he's spending a decent amount of time
out there lester i'm having a little
trouble myself seeing if he's still
waving or making hand gestures but he is
obviously
no he mostly just took the mask off
that's it and i can hear now
the rotor is getting louder which makes
me think marine one is about to take off
but you can see his photographer there
coming in it looks like on the left side
of the screen
with the american flags flanking him i'm
told lester that
as the president is isolating uh at the
white house
we should expect and we can expect to
continue to see appearances like we've
seen so far
as he's been spending time at walter
reed he's blasted out every day that
he's been there
videos on twitter for example he did
that drive-by over the weekend i'm told
that the president will want to continue
to make these appearances
during the perhaps oh my god this is
such a fabricated stage managed photo op
trump oh now they've turned on stage
lighting so you can really make sure
that they get pictures
of trump saluting the hell oh my god
this is like authoritarian dystopian
nightmare
they had to get the lights on so you
could really see his salute
i see the president obscured by marine
one
as it lifts off and the president
remains on the balcony
i'm cringing so marine one will go
lester and then when president trump
walks back into the residence it is a
question mark of when we will see him
next
as it looks like he perhaps delivers a
salute there
he is the figure of course in the middle
of the screen flanked by those american
flags
so the president will now head inside
the residence with a wave
to the assembled crew reporters down
there not sure if he's
saying anything yelling unclear but
we'll be able to tell the audience
once we do get what's called lester tate
playback when those reporters
run that video right back into the rack
room here at the white house and feed it
out to us yeah so
donald trump is back after a miraculous
recovery of only 72 hours at walter reed
medical center
donald trump has flown back to the white
house
wearing only a 10 cent mask not
no n95 um walked up the steps under his
own power
and immediately took off the mask
and now i guess is walking around the
white house with no mask
exposing more people and we we
soon are going to get the i'll stay with
you guys so we can get this high
resolution
video that was filmed from the other
side as you heard this shot is a very
zoomed in
shot from very far away and
uh we we these are just completely
you know cringe-worthy scenes this
reminds me of when kim jong-il
uh despite never having played golf
before got hole in ones
on 18 he shot an 18 um
as well as um controlling rainbows
and i mean it's it's you know that's the
type of stuff that we are experiencing
right now it's
completely unbelievable and of course
speculation is that donald trump is
feeling okay now
because he's on a very powerful
corticosteroid dexamethasone which makes
people feel great
and sometimes aggressive and sometimes
manic and sometimes a side effect is
delusions of grandeur which of course
you know you wouldn't be able to tell
the difference with donald trump but
that's
uh that's what's going on now brian
bringing up something that many
many of us are thinking they've upgraded
trump will go through an icu
will go through icu hidden in the white
house while staffers tweet for him and
his doctor tells us
he's training for the boston marathon
that's a little exaggerated
but many have posited that many many
have posited that indeed the white house
has been rigged up
as an icu and that is part of why
donald trump now can be back at the
white house
and i don't really even understand
what's going on now
or or what is taking place at the white
house
um but we are expecting momentarily
some better video of donald trump
getting off of the helicopter
uh here we have some zoomed in videos of
the back of the white house or i guess
what would i guess this is technically
the front maybe and what we're used to
seeing is actually the back
having some white balance issues
certainly as we uh
as we keep an eye on all of this live
images
soul brand has subscribed on twitch and
says david let's
un-rat [ __ ] this election by running up
the score as much as we can
yes yes yes a kinky turtle
has gifted two tier one subscriptions
yeah good okay glad to see that
super guy says if biden wins florida is
that it for trump more than likely
pyroplasma says when did you become a
jedi master and what tips do you have
for those of us
aspiring for such a coveted title
um i'd have to think about that
i'd have to think about that i guess
we're still looking at donald trump i
guess that's still
donald trump there um
let's see if there's more of a zoomed in
shot here no this is more zoomed out
it's anybody's guess what's going on
right now at the white house
peggy harkness says i had coveted in
march i am still sick and i was a
healthy middle-aged woman
mid-age woman yeah nathan shocker says
epic pen is great for drawing on videos
or desktop
okay i'll have to look into that
four is says drinking a forty and
smoking a blizzy thank you pacman
trump is trump back oh no this is
moments ago okay
that's when he took the mask off
heroically uh we're waiting for
for video to be turned around
momentarily bay photo wonders whether
dexamethasone will be trump's new go-to
upper yeah much more powerful right than
whatever it is he's been using
by the way oh major announcement i want
to mention this right now because we've
got
25 000 people watching tomorrow i i know
i'm a risk
i'm risking this by announcing it before
it happens
i am scheduled to be interviewing
anthony scaramucci tomorrow i will be
asking him what is it what does he know
about trump's drug use
how does he feel about having lied for
trump for so long
uh tomorrow anthony scaramucci on the
david pakman show
no question off the table okay
no question off the table the connection
was made
because anthony scaramucci and i both
are featured
in a forthcoming documentary
about the trump presidency
i guess i shouldn't say the name of the
documentary yet
only because um i don't know how much of
it
has has been announced but yes tomorrow
mark it down
october 6th anthony scaramucci
a wide-ranging interview uh
on the david pakman show the way you
will first be
able to get that would be on the podcast
okay
here we have the video turned around all
right uh hallie this is this is
yeah this is the full video now shot
moments ago we'll let it play it out
trump's back everybody
no n95 as you can see
full orange makeup as we predicted
[Music]
mr president are you a super spreader
[Music]
and then presumably we will see him at
the top of the stairs then remove the
mask right away this may be the most
orange he's ever looked although
the sunset may be playing a role in that
here is donald trump and it looks like
this was of course a planned moment
where donald trump would
remove the mask there it is going first
right
uh ear loop off then left
and then saluting for some pictures his
breathing actually it actually does look
like he's having trouble breathing
see his it normally he does not breathe
like that
but it is what it is i mean listen he
does have coronavirus after all
so now he's calling it looks like he's
directing the photo shoot having the
photographer
come and stand behind him you can see
trump looks like visibly struggling to
breathe i would say
and calling for this completely
ridiculous
photo op buttoning the suit of course he
wants to have the photography look a
certain way
then he saluted the helicopter uh
as it started to spin up and they even
turned lights on
trump he really seems to be sucking for
air this does not look like a healthy
trump i think you guys will agree with
me
and there is the salute a planned he
directed the photographer to stand
behind him
then you can hear now the helicopter
spooling up
and then it looked like just to get an
even better photo op you'll see the
lights go on very very powerfully at a
certain point here
you can see the flash bulb now
and momentarily they sort of redo it
with the lights on bright
in a moment it's not unlike his
recent trip to a church across the
street from the white house during
black lives matter protests president
obviously trying to make
a very strong statement of strength here
but removing his mask albeit maybe no
one in front of him
he's clearly making a statement
perhaps a symbol of strength perhaps a
symbol symbol of defiance
yeah something like that a man who was
rushed to the hospital in a helicopter
just three days ago facing covet 19
which is a death sentence for a lot of
people
taking his mask off and standing and
posing for pictures
teflon don is back ladies and gentlemen
he is back and as you noticed when the
rotor wash
started to go there he did uh step back
a little bit it did
the front of it of his hair was uh sort
of sort of waving in the wind there like
a flag and that
is as we know a very very big priority
for donald trump he does not want his
hair to
look the wrong way so very strongly and
very quickly
backing up there and donald trump is
back
defiantly removing his mask ready to
continue spreading the virus
uh to the degree that he is able within
the white house and maybe very soon even
at a debate uh the big news from about
90 minutes ago that donald trump
plans to plans to be at the debate
adjust what are we uh wait ten
ten no wait seven eight nine yeah ten
days from today
ten days from today plans to plans to be
at the debate although we certainly
don't know for sure
daniel 84 has subscribed on twitch with
the message
does subscribing to david for 15 months
make me a
gamma male actually daniel you are now
theta
theta male for subscribing for 15 months
um asw with the message it started
ironically like nobody has ever heard of
but now i can't stop bigly talking like
trump everyone is talking about it
vote yeah vote is the most important
part of that message
uh a lot can happen as people are
pointing out between now and the next
day of the next debate
i hope i hope i hope that you will join
me wednesday night 8 30 p.m
in the east 5 30 p.m in the west
for vp debate kamala harris
versus mike pence uh she has requested
plexiglas i support that request pence
said
no pence said no
and we will have that debate for you
wednesday evening if you want to be
notified of that debate stream if you're
watching on youtube
hit the subscribe button if you're
watching on twitch
hit the follow button and if you're
watching on facebook
make sure to hit that like button we
will be back with you
very very soon thank you for joining me
donald trump
back at the white house and remember if
you know
how to set up a wacom tablet which i
just got
to be able to tell a straight over
video please let me know because i would
love to know how to do it thank you
you